I have a fantastic decision to tell you about
that was made by a panel of judges in North
Carolina.
Now it's just one decision and it is a much
broader problem gerrymandering than one decision
can fix, but this is the right decision that
was made and that's what matters in this particular
case.
The way that Republicans drew the district
lines in North Carolina does not quote permit
voters to freely choose their representative
according to Superior Court decisions that
have been, uh, filed and the districts cannot
remain drawn this way.
The maps according to this ruling in North
Carolina were specifically drawn, no surprise.
We've known this for years to maintain a republican
super majority in the state legislature.
This is what North Carolina Republicans are
known for.
This is what North Carolina Republicans have
been doing and succeeding with for a very
long time.
Now, there's an interesting sort of legal
circumstance here that's important to understand.
You might remember that just a few months
ago, the Supreme Court ruled that you cannot
challenge partisan gerrymandering in federal
court and yet here we have a superior court
making this decision.
But there is a rule in the North Carolina
constitution called the free elections clause,
which specifically says you cannot do partisan
gerrymandering.
Partisan gerrymandering according to the North
Carolina Constitution is um, uh, unconstitutional.
And that is what led to this decision being
made in North Carolina.
Even though conceivably if it had been appealed
or attempted to be appealed up to the Supreme
Court, the Supreme Court would not have taken
up a given their prior decision in June.
So the right decision in North Carolina, we
know that this has been going on.
What happens now with the districts in North
Carolina.
Um, there is a deadline until September 18
lawmakers will have to redraw new maps, which
if they are fairly redrawn, they could give
Democrats a chance to actually do some damage
in the North Carolina state legislature in
2020 and hopefully pick up some seats.
If Democrats can pick up the majority in the
North Carolina state legislature in November
of 2020 then they will be in charge of drawing
the maps after the 2020 census in 2021 which
would be great.
But again, this is where Democrats and Republicans
where left and right are not the same.
I have no interest in Democrats taking over
the majority in the North Carolina state legislature
in November of 2020 and then redrawing districts
in a completely unfair away that benefits
Democrats.
Now you could say it would be a just outcome
because Republicans have done it for nearly
the entire period between the 2010 and the
2020 census.
Republicans in North Carolina deserve to have
the lines redrawn in a way that favors Democrats
instead of Republicans.
We don't need to cheat to win.
I just want fair maps.
Fair maps are what I want, not diferently
unfair maps that now benefit Democrats.
Uh, when it comes to a lot of these issues,
I am not looking to reverse the structural
advantage that Republicans have unfairly created
for themselves and create it for the left.
I just want fair maps because I know that
with fair maps and voter turnout, meaning
everybody is allowed to vote, who wants to
vote and their votes are counted.
I know that that's enough for us to win.
Uh, however, it's completely plausible that
the maps that are redrawn in North Carolina
between now and September 18th, 18th, will
simply be slightly less, obviously unfair
to Democrats, but still heavily slanted towards
Republicans.
That's a realistic possibility.
One of the things about gerrymandering is
that there's a huge incentive to do it even
if it later is going to be tossed out because
people who were elected under gerrymandered
districts don't lose their seats.
If the districts are found to have been gerrymandered
and the map has to be changed, your election
under a gerrymandered map doesn't become null
and void.
If the district maps are later determined
to be unconstitutional, which is why they
keep doing it.
You have a census in 2010 the next year they
draw bonkers crazy districts.
They win seats, they maintain a super majority.
Then they can actually push what they want
in terms of bills becoming law for one election
for two elections, whatever.
Meanwhile, Democrats have to fight them in
court on the way the districts were drawn
and then if a few years later the districts
end up being tossed out.
You picked up the seats, the winters were
there.
They got to pass bills, they got to make laws
and then you get the keep those seats.
Even if the judge says that the districts
ultimately have to be redrawn, this is the
evil genius of partisan gerrymandering.
Even if you later lose the other side has
to spend a ton of time and money fighting
the drawing of the districts and you get to
keep all of those seats that the gerrymandering
helped you win in the first place.
That's why it's so pernicious.
This is why the census matters so much and
this is why we need a, there are models.
There are endless academicians who have put
together models for how you should draw districts.
Computers can do it.
You don't need people saying, let's shift
this around and include this weird protuberance
in this district because it's advantageous.
It's, it's completely unnecessary.
This is actually something that can, computers
can do very well and very fairly, uh, as Trump
says, it's amazing what even kids like baron
Trump are doing with computers these days.
We don't need partisan gerrymandering.
We don't even need partisan involvement in
drawing these districts anymore.
So the right decision in North Carolina to
some extent too little too late because Republicans
in North Carolina have gotten so much out
of the way they've drawn these districts over
the last several election cycles.
Make sure you are following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman.
Show a lot of funny stuff there and while
you're on Instagram, make sure you follow
me at David Dot pacman.
We will take a quick break and [inaudible]
that's coming up next.
We will talk about Donald's prompts, sharpie
gauge,